a typical training week varies each
month depending on what phase of the
season we're in but more or less we have
two relatively easy days a week which
usually consists of cruise run and an
easy swim the other days of the week
consists of two hard runs too hard bike
workouts and then two hard swims it's
taken me a really long time to figure
out my nutrition as an athlete you
really need to understand that you're
feeling to perform prior to using
science and sport and race I really
struggle on the run whether it was from
a lack of nutrition or from stomach
issues from other products race day and
training don't vary too much especially
on high-intensity days I really rely on
the science and sport isotonic gels to
get me through hard sessions because
that's the only thing my stomach can
handle when I'm putting out a really
solid effort during some of my easier
sessions I like to have the science and
sport go energy bars and then after
every training session I have at least a
scoop or two of rego recovery and I feel
really helps me recover faster or just
get in a few extra calories between
sessions so that I can train to the best
of my ability
[Music]